um against voittachek on a
on a regular uh basis he has a very good
score but he lost one time
in in like so yeah yeah i think he
played the dutch and he was pushing his
pawn to
i think to a3 castle a5 quincy two very
logical from
uh roytashek c6 knight bd2 he wants
e4 because black didn't
develop here b6 e4 bishop b7
offering why to gain some more space by
e5 but radek
just waits for this time and
probably waiting for knight bd7 to play
e5 yeah probably
play knight either d7 or knight a6
knight a6 you want to hit the queen here
that's what makes a lot of sense a3 i
guess
the most logical move and that will
create them
knight a6 and now he played e5 okay
97 now cds somewhat surprising
can i take with the knight i will play c
i think with the knight is
that's not not very right before was
played by
what champion and you mean that after cd
you want
a3 now yeah but okay you go knight c
section
51 played
to the world champion it's a bit of slow
play this is early middle game where
uh people start to think
i mean everybody is out of book
basically yeah but to be honest
i think world champion
has a position which he might not enjoy
very much
to develop yeah it's uh yeah i know of
course
but uh yeah it's not so funny
i'm not so sure the first short break
while
we'll be uh coming back to the deal of
the day of course
he goes there so he played rook c8 that
was our line
okay you how did he do it actually he
played bishop a6 first which is a clever
move
and which prevents bishop d2 bishop c3
because every time you play bishop d2
bishop d3
and that's tough
knight e3 roxy8
a3 knight c6
b3 yes he wants to prevent a
a4 and knife a5 where
magnus didn't play what we liked this is
bishop e2
followed by taking and then playing f6
he played b5
so you want to gain some space on the
queen side but you
so probably b4 is next but
look i don't see where it's going after
b4 a4
how do you continue yeah this position
actually i can still do the same i can
still play bishop
too and is it an improved
version it's upon h4 spawn b4
well i i mean this h4 only stops uh
g5 a bit but on the other hand uh well
if i if you want to play uh
yeah he's taking his time he played
before
magnus carson a4 has to be
expected just to to close to to close
down
the the queen side
a4 played very logical
in the spirit played f6 bishop g4
he didn't take only five we're expecting
that he played f5
it takes maybe he was afraid of some
bishop h4 now
that could go on very fast actually yeah
for for white took on f5
take stakes and this is a very very
interesting position
wow peace sacrifice by
radek for itashik
and they say bishop h4 is a move
that cece is recommending king h8 now
apparently is the first
move by cece who is changing his mind
this means how difficult is this
position
okay i was trying to he played bishop h4
wow wow wow
so the evaluation bar as usual is
showing zeros i'm sure
on a stronger computer it would show the
same i mean it's always the same
class is a draw what can we do but in a
practical game
could go either way this is completely
clear
yeah that's just amazing actually let's
let's show it
one more time knight d4 and now
it's coming so that's way too dangerous
i thought this offered by the chat is
not stupid at all
and even queen g5 i thought it's good
for
white maybe here i can go king g2 bishop
e3
f4 yeah positionally you're very fine
yeah
the bishop is great on g6 and the bishop
on e7 is simply dead and uh
king of the night knight knight on d7
also not looking great
but after queen g6 i think the move is
knight d5 d5
knight e55 queen h5 and queen g5 now
and we have a problem
uh because knight f3 is very annoying
and he took on h4
wow yeah no let's say that now he took
an h4 of course that was our um
main move okay knight e5 apparently
what's the best move
ah he played bishop v6 check okay here
king h8 will come
what instantly ready i mean you are not
going to pin your horn hook
the blitz salt what else knight e5
will come it came
can i even play bishop b7 here i don't
want to give the queen g4
check but okay
and we have a first result uh
vladimir putin's af bit bladislav
kovalev
as white so today at least this is not a
game we have time to to cover but
there's so many games that
it's just impossible to to cover
everything
and this game is really fascinating
fascinating fascinating
check and take i don't know
i mean chicken takes that's kitty
let's get it but it's just a pawn yeah
yeah if i yeah play something like that
yeah
yeah i don't know i feel black will
always have some kind of perpetual or
something i mean like let's say if i go
if i go queen c4 you probably go kg1 if
i go queen g4 you
will have to okay you can play bishop g2
but looks a bit weird that's fine
h4h3 can might come
yeah black should be should be okay yeah
but
nothing more than that maybe so he took
on d5 okay i didn't
have this uh i didn't get that
information
okay so no no no no congestry
so what do you think this will do what
else
okay it's getting concrete it's getting
incredibly complete
eleven moves to make
for both
unclear if we will get to the time
control
so let's check quickly some other games
what
yeah okay whom do you want
let's come back to the main game of the
round knight f3
okay he took
immediately you don't even think about
anything else take stakes bishop c8 will
come
you have to no choice
he took
and now h5 luft
h5 looks most natural to me
yeah because compared to h6 you just
want your your pawn to help
maybe at some point the attack or do you
want to take on b3
oh i'm not that greedy come on
but now with bishop b2 have this
little check little annoying check
collecting the hook so yes
he played okay fate quickly but
uh not much choice for manuscripts and
this means six minutes on the clock
while waitacheck has 13 minutes
does he mean that he don't have too many
squares for the bishop
um yeah i don't know but uh
but rook takes b3 was also very uh
i mean he calls by rook c3 takes b3
how very tempting yeah many um i'm just
curious about the
evaluation there
okay both square are not good
that one as well that one as well so
what happens if i play bishop b7
yeah okay that's let's go back i mean
i expect to back out of two to finish
that game bishop b7 so what did we miss
here
i i said you said rookie yet or what i
said okay
i said give me a toast
take here he played qf6
as far as i can see i like the
the rook b2 move
or rook a2 wow
and here can i just go
back with the bishop or not well
to g2
little check bishop g1 f1
because points here rook f6 i have
bishop g5 fantastic
these hawks are doing amazing defensive
uh defensive job and here you were just
quick joke and he played
what champion played queen f7 magnus
carlsen
attacking here attacking here
by voiter okay what he wants to take the
point now
yeah and then the guy is going to move
out against the pieces
i mean like bishop no bishop be free i
play of course he bishop p3
of course probably play something like
rook d8 so
otherwise i'll play rook d2 yeah okay
let's go with the 8 i like
i mean it doesn't look that easy to
untangle yeah of course it's not easy
yeah
yeah okay no you just um
sounded like it's a matter of time and
okay i will entangle
no it might be sharp take on h7 and mate
you
but it's no it's like it's not like um
if i untangle then i'm winning but yeah
yeah what you expected this to be a
short process um 35 moves
played and i think now he needs to
actually to
to to swap one blacks and this swap one
pair of rooks otherwise
i mean the rooks become a factor in
attacking the the black king
yeah that's true you will play with the
e8
that's a typical magnus move
that's the magnus move and it's played
yeah i mean he's good in
no he's good in chess yeah he's
extremely good in chess
but in such positions i think
especially like could
can play that as a machine yeah
while he missed i mean like let's face
it uh
he missed a clear win the fight which
was possible to find
i mean it was not nothing you mean not
hd5
yeah i think bishop h4 was more
difficult to spot than knight
e5 no i i i disagree
i think i think the knight takes e5 is
uh much harder to spot because after
bishop takes
h4 ontakes is for your natural instinct
is simply queen
okay and then and next move you take off
e5
can they no not easy because if you go
d2 for instance
i can just take take and now some tricks
are coming
even queen okay okay still
okay so i shouldn't do that
maybe i should make a square for my poor
little king
say something like that now h5
you did entangle actually i
just missed one pair of rocks but yeah
i'm going here
i have little brother you know
wants to become a big um
lady bishop bishop bishop
bishop
okay check
will be it
little trick for you yeah i was not sure
that if the bishop had to go to e3 that
was a kind of
uh easy to lose for white two
minutes and fifty seconds four with a
check and this
another i mean all the positions are
critical but that one is probably
the last one before the time control
move 35 but very important moment
crucial moment
we'll probably have some more results
coming in
not yet seems uh
seems mr bakotov is completely winning
just uh small
g8 is coming yeah he's kind of
dominating the night
huh what happened you're talking
what do you mean some draw offer
wow that's shocking actually
because magnus never
ah so it came with a draw offer
he never does that it's very very rare i
think the last time you offered the door
it was against caruana in this game
famous
in famous game 12. but it was incredibly
sharp but he was doing very well and now
you first do also
okay because i i don't think you
i think i like i like white still
okay
that's not the magnus who i used to to
see actually
to fodo you generally plays especially
the computer showing some slight
black advantage but
no it's at all
not yet seems uh
seems mr bakotov is completely winning
just
uh small obj8 is coming
yeah he's kind of dominating the night
huh what happened
you're talking
what do you mean some draw offer
wow that's shocking actually
because magnus never
ah so it came with a draw offer
he never does that it's very very rare i
think the last time you've heard the law
it was against caruana in this game
famous
in famous game 12. it was incredibly
sharp but he was doing very well
and now your first door so
okay because i i don't think
i think i like i like whites too
okay
that's not the magnus who i used to to
see actually
to fodo you generally place especially
the computer is showing some slight
black advantage but
no it's at all
what do you mean some draw offer
wow that's shocking actually
because magnus never
ah so it came with a draw offer
he never does that very very rare i
think the last time you heard the law it
was against caruana in this game famous
in famous game 12. it was incredibly
sharp but he was doing very well and now
your first door
so okay
because i i don't think i think i like i
like
whites too
okay
that's not the magnus who i used to to
see actually
to photo you generally place especially
the computer is showing some slight
black advantage but
no it's at all